what is going on girls and guys welcome
to another Jenga tutorial in this
tutorial we're gonna be talking about
templating the idea of templating is
pretty simple to understand the the
concept behind it is consider you've got
a website most websites look very
similar page to page this is because
they use what we call in the HTML
circles headers and footers okay and so
the idea there is that you've got nav
bars let's say and the nav bar is
something you include in your header
file and this way on every page the
navigation bar is identical then when it
comes time to change the navigation bar
you just have to edit one file rather
than editing 100 files or even more
right so so we use we use templates to
do that and in for Python in with major
Python frameworks we use Jinja so Jinja
is a templating framework built with
Python working with Python in mind it is
not Python in HTML there are a lot of
things in Python that you just can't do
with ginger but ginger can do a lot of
logic that at least gets us pretty far
with writing dynamic and logical ish
HTML and there are actually some things
in ginger that you can do that you can't
do in Python just based on the fact that
we're writing in HTML so anyways let's
go ahead get started the first thing
we're going to do is this project the
idea here is to create a personal
website and about you website so we're
going to start a new app because web app
doesn't really fit that bill so we're
going to go ahead and I'm going to
specify the full path to Python as usual
again you don't have to do that most
likely so anyway Python managed pi start
app and this one I'm going to call
personal because that because it's
personal yell now first thing you do
when you start an app there are a few
things but the very first thing you have
to do install the app so move this side
go to my site settings dot PI and we
install the app right now I've got web
app we'll just
add a new one and this app is personal
so we've installed if you have I'm going
to delete web app we're not actually
going to be using it anyway so done and
what is the second thing you pretty much
always are going to have to do well yeah
I have a link that sends people to the
app so in the URLs dot PI file let's
edit that and in most cases you'll be
able to just fall I'm going to leave
this here we are going to get rid of it
just like we got rid of web app but in
most cases you'll you'll probably follow
this structure that I'm about tree so
I'll take one of the previous lines
that's including write another app
copy/paste done and then instead of web
app dot URLs it's personal die URLs that
doesn't exist yet we will make it don't
worry and we've got the path the path
really the personal website is the crux
of our website so what URL path should
link to it well the index path so
basically the string that goes caret
dollar sign again that means that's the
beginning of the string the string ends
so the index page right if there is no
other link assigned to the path right
it's just the home page we want to
include personal URLs we don't have web
app dot URL or web app even installed
anymore so I'm going to delete that so
this includes personal that URL so
that's the next thing that we need to
make so quit go back a directory we've
pretty much removed all web app so I'm
gonna delete web app you can leave it
there if you want doesn't matter and
into personal we don't have a URLs dot
PI and personal and in fact we're going
to copy and paste from the other URLs PI
so back to my site and just open up the
my site / URLs PI move that aside for
now and back to personal and make a new
file call URLs PI we're going to edit it
and I'm going to take basically all this
code copy paste we do have to make a
quite a few modifications but it's going
to be ok everyone
so um we can leave this we actually
don't need that URL but we'll leave it
there
and the next thing that we want to have
is we don't need to admin so we're going
to delete that because we're deleting
that let's make sure we get rid of that
and now what we need to do is on the in
the local URL stop dot PI file instead
of including URLs like we have in the
main one what we add typically are going
to be doing is returning views so what
we need to do is remember that we go
from period or relative import use so
once you've got that you come down here
and rather than the home page so
basically that URL is is going to say
hey let's check out the other URLs up
high and what we're saying here is if if
the URL remains caret dollar sign as in
it's a home page which it absolutely
must be we're going to include well
we're not actually going to include so
I'm going to delete this what we are
going to do is we're going to return the
views index because that's what it
corresponds to and then don't forget
comma the name space will be just index
so at this point you should be
questioning hey do I have a view index
right because we're trying to return
that so save that exit that head into
views and we look and I nope we don't
have a views dot index so let's go ahead
and create one so we're going to say
define index because we have to the
obligatory parameter here is always
request you got to pass it I think it's
just to be explicit you know it'd be
easier if you didn't have to like keep
passing that through but with Django
explicit is nice anyway a lot of stuff
is magical we are going to return and
before we return that HTTP response
that's really not going to be your main
method of returning anything so and as
you might even be able to guess that the
main one is actually a render right so
in that so if you're actually using
views at PI later on I'll show you
actually a lot of people don't even use
a views dot pi and I'll show you why but
if you are using a views up pi chances
are you are going to be returning a
render so return render and
have to pass the obligatory request and
then you pass the location of the HTML
template you want to render so we're
going to return personal slash home dot
HTML okay that's all we're going to do
you can also pass a dictionary and the
dictionary will be then passed to your
template which you can then use Jinja to
pull apart your dictionary and do all
kinds of cool stuff but for now we'll
keep it simple so personal slash home
dot HTML so let's go ahead and head to
personal here and what's happening are
we going to put a personal the HTML file
right here no so return is going to or
render is going to want to return
thinking of flask really anyway
the return render template I suppose if
I was thinking of lousy actually anyway
back on topic so this is going to render
and it's the place that render looks is
actually in a templates directory so my
site personal and then you're going to
have a new folder here called
templates and here's the kicker every
app is probably going to have templates
right that corresponds to that app and
you actually can in templates you can
put your code right or your HTML files
right in here that that's totally
acceptable
Django will find them the problem is
consider you got your your personal app
website might have it for example a
header and a footer file may be usually
nowadays we the header and footer is
actually all contained in the header but
you might actually you might have a home
page right so for example your forum
might have a home your blog might have a
home dot HTML so then these would create
conflicting names
so what Django does is it takes all your
apps and then for templates what it does
is it takes all your apps takes all your
templates and loads them all and
basically has access to all of them as
if they were all stored in a single
template study or templates directory so
if you have two templates that
the identical name this can be a problem
so you have two to two ways to get
around this one is to never call any
template the same as any other template
this can be a challenge though to
remember to do so the other thing is to
just have a principle where in this
templates directory you have another
directory that is again personal this
can seem redundant but it is going to
save you so that's what you should do
feel free to not do that if you don't
want to you just have to add that path
basically when you're going to return
the files but that's going to save you
and also it's part of the official
documentation so follow it
so anyways impersonal we need a new file
and what if I have I guess we don't
really have any files so new and I was
really hoping let's see okay so what I
got to do here is open up like a notepad
plus plus you can actually use notepad
but I wouldn't recommend it and what we
want to do is actually save a new file
to this you know personal templates
personal so personal templates personal
and what I'm going to call this file is
going to be our this will be our hope
like I guess this will be our this will
be our header so we're going to make our
header and then the file type is HTML so
this is our header HTML so save that and
in here we're going to put some HTML now
I think what we'll do to save time
there's really no reason to hand type
out this HTML so I'm going to copy it
paste it the source code for this is the
tutorial all tutorials are hosted on
Python programming at net all the source
code is there I'm going to instead just
explain the source code when I copy and
paste it so what's happening here we're
just defining the doctype and the
document type basically is HTML we give
the language as English though we can
add some other stuff
you're on but we'll just keep it super
basic this is the head this is just like
some header header information so this
stuff actually doesn't get seen in the
main window the title will actually be
the title of the tab in most browsers
but a lot of this stuff is like metadata
so like this is meta it's a saying you
know the character set is utf-8 and so
on then you have the body this is the
main body of the page so this is where
most of your content is going to wind up
one thing you'll notice is we've got
this information if you're familiar with
HTML you've probably never seen this
before this is Jinja so as you can see
there's really nothing here that we're
saying hey use Jinja this is just it
just is used
okay so Django flask whatever is just
going to recognize this as Jinja so
we've got block content block body
what's going on here is we'll the next
thing we do is define a file that's
going to basically fill in the between
these tags basically these are a logic
tags so when you see like a a curly
braces and a percentage sign followed by
the closing that is Jinja logic
conversely the following is the ginger
variable we'll talk about both and
you'll see both as we progress here but
for now we've got block content at end
block so we can now define something
that will actually fill in these spaces
basically so let's go ahead and save the
header dies or the head or no hetero
HTML and then now what we want to go
ahead and do is we actually want to make
another file and we're going to call it
home when I exit this for now I'm just
going to copy and paste this one call it
home open it with notepad make it bigger
and now we want to do is actually we
don't really need any of this definition
stuff we're going to now define what
will go between the block content and
the end block to do that what we're
going to say is we're going to start off
with some logic and the logic first will
be that this extend
and then you give the path to what is it
extending starting with templates so
starting at the templates directory this
is going to extend personal slash hetero
HTML again we just have one app but
later we are going to have many apps and
other apps can extend this template even
though it's not included in the
templates directory of that app it
doesn't matter Django is going to load
them all and consider them all at slash
templates it's very cool
another thing that it will do is the
same thing for like static files it's
going to do the same thing which I'll
show you later on so this is basically
absolutely necessary that Django does
this of course but it also is very kind
of confusing initially like how is it
possibly knowing how to get to these
anyway so this extends that file so when
you extend a file it's going to be
looking for okay what is that block body
or block content and end block so we're
going to literally take this copy come
over here
paste and what we whoops and what we now
put between here is going to be simply
placed between here and really when you
extend something the page that you you
return or render is this page so it
loads up this page which is home HTML
and then it extends this header page so
you would never you could load the
header page but really you're always
loading the page that you were actually
you know extending to I suppose anyway
so that so we can just put like some
simple paragraph text in here and I'm
just gonna say hey welcome to my
websites I am a programmer okay good
enough so we can save that now what we
have is hopefully everything we need
we'll go ahead and start see if we get
any errors so I'm just going up instead
of manage that pi start app we're going
I run server and it looks like
everything worked out so far if I go to
the site sure enough we get the homepage
hey welcome to iOS our programmer and so
let me go back to here yes so the views
dot pi that we're rendering that it
corresponds to this home page basically
again is actually personal home HTML not
header but if we view source which is
control u for example in Chrome you'll
see that we got all that other
information in fact we don't even have
the ginger logic we just have the HTML
that was generated generated by the
ginger logic okay so that's pretty
pretty cool now the next thing I want us
to go ahead and do is cover one more way
of including or getting ahead of myself
one more way of but it's true including
HTML and other HTML so for example one
thing that I like to do is like it's
like for example with extends this can
be somewhat restrictive because like
what if you want to extend what if you
want to include multiple HTML snippets
in one HTML file that can get kind of
messy uh especially because like which
one gets included like are they included
in order or you know what so so another
method that we have is instead of using
the extends logic we can use logic that
is includes so again we add some logic
and this logic is going to be include
and then in quotes um again you're going
to use start in slash templates so slash
templates is assumed then we're going to
say personal and then we could say a
file we want to include but sorry guys
we're going to make another directory
and I call this directory includes the
reason for this is includes is generally
very short snippets of code and I like
to keep keep things as organized as
possible here a lot of times you you
start off like with maybe like five
templates okay and as your website grows
soon enough you've got like 25
item plates and then with includes you
might have another hundred includes or
something so I always like to have
includes in a separate directory so
we're going to include personal includes
and then I'm just going to call this
HTML snippet dot HTML so we'll save that
that doesn't exist so we have to make it
so we will come over this over we don't
need views and we're already in
templates personal now I make a new
directory
I call it includes I'm just going to
copy home into there for now go into
includes edit with notepad and you'll
see that actually with includes it's not
so restrictive and the reason it's not
so restrictive is see like with here
with this old um oh this is so called
home dot HTML let me let me rename it
before we go editing it
this was HTML snippet I believe now
let's try it the reason why it's not so
restrictive is we can do this BAM so now
it's not only going to extend a certain
page or be included with a certain page
instead it can be included anywhere and
then we're not going to do this like
infinite loop of including so get rid of
that too and we'll make this look at me
I am included say that so then you can
include this on to many pages you can
include it multiple times even like you
could just like include then include
again it's not a big deal you can just
kind of add these wherever you want and
you can add multiple includes so
generally with extends you're going to
extend the pages that will be extended
or pages that are going to be present
all over your website includes are
things that are present in a lot of
places but not necessarily like
everywhere
so you would extend a page that is like
your header and footer of your website
something that's like there all the time
that's why you would be explicit but
with HTML snippets you just would
basically you would just only include
them because you don't actually want to
extend a page and then be restricted by
the regime the restrictive Ness
of extents so now if we shouldn't
actually have to refresh anything so
let's just come back to our website
refresh and now you see yep look at me
I'm included sure enough if we go to the
home or the source code you can see that
there's an again no ginger logic it's
just the text that was rendered okay so
there's like the basics of ginger
templating the extreme basics we haven't
covered variables and and really that
much ginger logic but as you can see you
can probably start to do some pretty
cool stuff even with just this
information in the next tutorial what
we're gonna be talking about is a little
bit more of like styling because right
now our website obviously I mean this is
very ugly website you wouldn't actually
share this website with anybody I'm not
promising that what you'll have at the
very end is something you'll want to
share but it at least be a whole lot
better than this so the next tutorial
we're going to talking about HTML and
CSS luckily for us programmers there is
a lovely lovely thing called bootstrap
so that's what we're going to be talking
about the next tutorial is incorporating
bootstrap into our project so stay tuned
for that if you have questions comments
concerns whatever leave them below
otherwise as always thanks for watching
thanks for all the support and
subscriptions in it till next time